bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
francesc emmanuel macron à raison selon
goût de faire ainsi pression sur londres
oui bonjour
demande depuis longtemps le monde depuis
longtemps parce que on sait très bien
qu'avec avec les anglais il faut mettre
la pression sinon ils ne lâcheront
voilà c'est surtout ça mais ce qu'il n'y
a pas de risques au quotidien dans leur
travail dans votre travail pour les
pêcheurs français londres menace en
représailles d'intensifier les contrôles
des navires européens
bon le risque pour nous et
non il n'y a pas beaucoup de risques et
menaces que les bateaux qui ne peuvent
pas aller dans les eaux anglaises risque
que de déposer le bilan est bon ben
voilà il y aura peut-être quelques
heures en mer avec les anglais mais
voilà les peler les pêches les pêcheurs
même les pêcheurs anglais 1 ils veulent
entrer dans nos à nous c'est pas ces
mystoires politique surtout voilà nous
demande d'aller travailler et aussi
et surtout vendre leur poisson chez nous
c'est surtout ça vous que ce n'est pas
une forme de harcèlement avec ces
contrôles qui pourrait s'intensifier
j'avais harcèlement un peu plus que ce
qu'on a déjà on contrôle
beaucoup
beaucoup plus un poil est déjà pas mal
contrôlée régulièrement les contrôles on
est habitué les pêcheurs sont habitués
donc finalement ça ne vous fait pas peur
visiblement quelle solution à ce que
vous voyez pour que pêcheurs français et
britanniques continuent de travailler
paisiblement ensemble parce que
finalement c'est ce à quoi tous aspirent
on imagine
qu'on accepte
on accepte les disques des licences
qu'on demande pour les bateaux qui vont
qui allaient dans ces zones là et qui
depuis le plus de la baie le début de
l'année pour certains bateaux dans les
eaux du royaume uni même n'ont pas été
bons pour les eaux des îles
anglo-normandes on allait vers gassion
est provisoire mais pour les bateaux les
bateaux hauturiers
les bateaux hauturiers baba je parle
pour les bretons il y en a certains qui
comprend pas mis les pieds dans l'est
dans les eaux anglaises depuis 2000
janvier et leur chiffre d'affaires un
très gros impact
quel argument est ce que rapporte
londres à cet effort français qui l'ont
toujours pas reçu leur licence pour
pêcher dans les eaux britanniques
battant grand chose pas grand chose il
apporte il apporte rien
ils disent qu'ils sont chez eux qu'ils
veulent à qui ces maîtres chez eux voilà
ce chose qui met en avant vous l'évoquez
tout à l'heure le sentiment de payer le
prix fort de tensions diplomatiques qui
dépasse le seul cas de la pêche
c'est sûr c'est sûr on savait on savait
très bien que avec le bruit site
breasseale duroux mexique doit il y aura
eu des
inconvénients on l'a le mieux comment
le traité n'est pas respectée
la
dignité de leurs paroles et où l'aîné le
royaume uni voilà c'était une histoire
de le
quelques 30 40 bateaux en coupe 1 les
zones
du royaume uni voilà
et le 80 on s'entend mais la leur leurs
péchés
vous avez l'air satisfait de la réponse
apportée par paris vis-à-vis de londres
qu'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement français jusqu où est-ce
qu'il doit aller pour que tous les
pêcheurs français obtiennent leur
licence de pêche dans les eaux
britanniques
jusqu'au bout ne pas mollir est resté
promettent promesses qui est-ce qui est
ce qu ils disent qu'ils ont promis serre
dont on sera vite on sera vite
renseigner parce que vous savez des
contrôles au départ des séries ou du
train ou des trains
ces 15 km de bouchons alors on saura si
les contrées où sont passés merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur arte france alain coudray
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
comité départemental des pêches de côtes
d'armor